In this video, I'm going to show you why
the anchored VWAP is a superior tool
when it's
paired with the fixed range volume
profile, okay? And for this example,
we're going to use the February monthly
open and the anchored February VWAP. And
just for context, the anchored VWAP is
the volume weighted average price
calculated from a specific starting
point that you choose
instead from a standard period like the
daily or weekly, but for this instance,
we will still anchor it to the monthly,
right? Um regular VWAP resets that's
every session. The anchored VWAP doesn't
reset. It tracks the rolling average
price by weighted volume, right? So when
from the moment you anchor it forward,
right? So what this actually represents
is the line is the aggregate cost basis
of every participant who's traded since
the anchor. If price is above the AVWAP,
the average buyer since that anchor is
in profit.
If price is below the anchored VWAP, the
average buyer is offside. That's why it
acts as a dynamic support and resistance
band, okay?
So basically, a session VWAP resets at
5:00 p.m. say Central Standard Time
every day and it's mostly just kind of
noise unless you're a session trader. An
anchored VWAP such as the monthly high
or the monthly open is anchored from uh
a certain place pivotal zone and then
you get uh from the happening or let's
say or a liquidation event, you can also
place those there and it's a regime line
with real instrument uh institutional
weight behind it, okay?
So you can do things at like the cycle
lows, okay? You can place a VWAP from
the cycle lows all the way down here.
You can place it from the cycle highs.
You can do all sorts of things like a
ETF approval, a happening, major news
where and then this kind of measures
where the post event cohort sits that
tried to trade that, right? Uh major
impulsive starts are also a very, very
popular one. So placing at an impulsive
move at the highs, right? You get the
You get the frame this however you want.
And you get to see where from this
impulsive move were buyers offsides or
on sides, okay?
Now,
what we're going to use for our
framework today is look at how to use
the VWAP in a trading environment that's
going to give you more profitability and
a better setup, okay?
So, when we zoom in on BTC here and we
look at the monthly open anchored VWAP,
mine is purple so I know which one is
the monthly. I keep my weeklies in
yellow so I know which one is the weekly
and the daily is always a light blue for
me. But, for this session we're just
going to focus on the monthly VWAP,
okay? So, when we had this impulsive
move down, which kind of is nice because
that was also the monthly open, we can
see how it acted as a dynamic resistance
band to everything, okay? Now, what I
like to do is take the fixed range
volume profile. And if you're on
TradingView, you're going to go ahead
and you're going to look at the
volume-based tools, right? So, you're
going to come over here, you're going to
open up your pane, and you're going to
have volume-based tools when we're
looking at the anchored VWAP and the
fixed range volume profile tool, right?
So, we're going to take the fixed range
volume profile and we're simply just
going to measure the range that is in
this dynamic price zone, okay? Now,
given, right? We're going to be focusing
on this zone here. So, as price is
playing out in this zone, this hasn't
happened yet, but you're starting to
make hypothesis and theories, so
for planning
a trade setup, okay?
We use the fixed range volume profile.
We have the value area high, the point
of control, and the value area low. You
can see exactly from each pivotal point
you it's acting with the monthly VWAP.
So, you have the value area high paired
with the monthly VWAP, resistance,
resistance, rejection, back down.
Resistance, resistance, rejection, back
down, okay? Now, it's very nice to pair
in this context because you could have a
nice short position here. You could have
a nice short position here. Uh for me
personally, I actually took a short
position here, paired this with the
three drives pattern. So, you have an
exhaustion pattern forming here on lower
time frames that you look for. You see
that it's coming up nicely into the
point of control, and then you have a
very, very nice pair with the monthly,
right? So, you SFP the POC once, and
then you reject off the monthly point of
control, and then you also have it
playing out further. So, when we go and
zoom back into this,
right?
You can clearly see,
and let's actually just pull this down
here so we can measure off exactly the
um trade that was taken, right? So, you
have your three drives, one, two, three.
You have a point of control rejection
off the monthly VWAP. Price ultimately
came back, flipped the point of control
to resistance, still tapped the monthly
or the value area high of this overall
fixed range profile as resistance, and
then the short is taken on the rejection
and loss of the VWAP paired with the
POC. Stops above the highs, and you look
to trade this down, okay? So, this is
one of those items that you can clearly
see is a very, very useful tool.
You honestly don't need much for this,
and even if you miss some sort of setup
like this as well, well, if you watch
the last video, then you can see that we
have a nice 618 back test. You take the
highs down to the lows. Price came up.
It rejected from the 618, 66, and the
72, and then even if it did make its way
up to the monthly VWAP and the point of
control, it'd be right there. So, we're
really only using the VWAP, the anchored
VWAP, the fixed range volume profile
tool, and then maybe some Fibonacci
retracement of your liking, okay? The
same can be used for another tool,
right? Or for another example here. If
we go ahead and we look at the current
pricing on BTC right now, right? Price
made a very nice swing low down here,
okay? We can go ahead and look at a
swing low setup. So, we have our swing
low. This is a major low, and then we go
ahead and we take a fixed range volume
profile off of this entire range. And
you can clearly see that once this VWAP
and this this anchored VWAP starts to
come up, you can see where the average
mean of price is. So, from a swing low,
um are buyers still from the last major
low here in profit, right? So, we can
see that yes, and it is acting as
support. Buyers are defending the VWAP.
We have a full rotation to the value
area high.
And you start to have really nice
context for that. You can see exactly as
the range develops as well, just by
using these two tools, how effective
price really can be, right? You have the
value area high, the point of control
acting as support, trying to expand out
of value and create new value, right?
Ultimately rejecting and flipping back
into value. You can see how dynamic that
just a swing low anchored VWAP is,
right? So, this is just placing it from
the lows of this entire move. You can
see how the nicely it acts as a dynamic
support band. I mean, just look, right?
You have resistance, resistance flipped
to support. You pair this simply just
with the point of control and the value
areas. So, you have another support. Um
and then ultimately when you lost this,
it flips back as to resistance, and now
we're down here, right? Now, you can
even pair this on higher time frames.
So, zooming out and looking at major
confluence. So, something like this as
well. Taking the swing low down here
when price is formed here. Again, as
this unfolds,
you get to see the bigger picture, but
it's simply you're taking a fixed range
volume profile, right? And you're
assessing where the anchored VWAP is.
You can see how beautifully it reacts,
and then ultimately when we lost this
entire range, you can see it flipped to
resistance twice, not once, but twice,
and then you know there's like going to
be a bigger downtrend for an expansion
move, right? And then, you know,
obviously anchor VWAP is also placed
very well at um when you get impulsive,
right? So, when you have impulsive moves
and swing swing highs and swing lows,
you can place it from higher. So, you
can start to pair
um where people are. So, when you're
placing it like this, are sellers still
from the last top, still in control?
Um yes, they definitely are. So, you can
see that, you know, buyers maybe had a
bit of you know, attempt to break out of
this value here, but ultimately sellers
still showed up around this VWAP,
right acted as resistance and then it
nuked the price down. The swing low view
up in this range still acted as
resistance and was lost and when you
have two pairings like that plus with a
larger fixed range volume profile and
you start to see something like this
well you know it's time to go short if
you haven't already and look for a
expansion move down and then you do
rinse and repeat and you trade the same
thing over and over and over and over
again and it's going to get you a lot of
really nice results, okay? That's
exactly why um if you go and follow us
on Discord and the the latest news um on
our profit and loss section we shorted
the 65k highs here and have rode this
down. Um there's a nice view up that
comes into here, right? So at the end of
the day when you start looking at
anchored view ups and you start to
understand the overall trend base with
them, how they work, the dynamic, uh and
the the liquidity and the overall
fundamentals and principles behind it
you can get a lot better trading and
this is really just using two different
tools. So if you guys like this video,
please give us a like, comment,
subscribe, and we'll see you in the
Discord. Cheers, guys.